according to the US Bureau of Labor
Statistics more than 500 truckers died
on the road last year that's more than
any other occupation and soon they may
be driving even more to better
understand the trucking lifestyle
Bloomberg News is Jennifer Oldham joined
driver Tracy Livingston for a trip
taking them more than 2,500 miles over
six days and Jennifer joins us now from
Denver Colorado Jennifer tell us about
your journey well I learned quite a bit
we spent six days on our trip I went
with a woman named Tracey Livingston and
we drove from Michigan down to Tennessee
back up to Michigan and then back down
to Kentucky and then back up to Michigan
and I learned that truck driving is so
much more than just driving she really
has a responsibility for this 80,000
pound piece of machinery that's 72 feet
long and avoiding all the traffic around
her and complying with state and federal
regulations and dealing with shippers
and receivers Jennifer tell us how the
new changes by Congress are going to
impact trucking standards well as part
of the budget bill there was a writer in
there that suspended provision that
required truckers who work 70 hours a
week to take 34 hours off including two
periods from 1:00 a.m. to 5:00 p.m.
they'll no longer have to take two
nights off which effectively could let
them work up to 82 hours and eight days
Jennifer give us a sense of how fatigue
is a very dangerous part of this
industry well I think truckers have a
very demanding career and it's really
more than a career it's a lifestyle and
they work they can work up to 14 hour
days and drive 11 hours of that and as
you can imagine on these long journeys
it's exhausting Jennifer what were your
expectations going into covering this
story and what did you learn I learned
that there is quite amount of stamina
required of these drivers and that
there's a lot of unexpected things that
happen that are
beyond their control and these sort of
things are cumulative I mean when you're
on a long-haul journey like that it
really adds up and it can really lead to
a lot of exhaustion Jennifer I have to
ask are there a lot of ladies who were
truckers my understanding is there's
more than there were although still it's
a very small fraction of the industry
all right Jennifer Oldham fresh fresh
offer literally fresh off of her twenty
five hundred mile trucking experience